[Music]
the video of Isis destroying the
artifacts in mushroom museum came out it
just felt like a really right moment to
do a project like this I don't think you
can really replace these these artifacts
what I've been trying to do has been to
at least figure out a way that I can
recreate them as accurately as possible
in a chaotic way I like to think about
this project as a way to resist that
removing of history or recreating a new
history that that Isis wants to do
[Music]
one of the things that I want to do for
the next versions of this project is to
have the information as well as files
that are 3d printable available to
public online so that everyone who has
access to 3d printers can 3d print them
I think as artists as activists this is
the least we can do to just find ways
metaphoric poetic artistic ways to
approach these issues around us
[Music]